this Ukrainian crew is driving a British
Challenger 2 tank
S Forces are training to maneuver
load ammunition and maintain Western
military vehicles ahead of their
delivery to the battlefield which the UK
says could be weeks away
so far in the war both Ukraine and
Russia have been using soviet-era tanks
such as the t-72 but the UK is one of
several NATO members including Germany
and the U.S that have offered to send
western-style tanks to Kiev
The Wall Street Journal visited the
Ukrainian troops learning to operate the
systems to find out the key technical
differences with Russian tanks
keep the grips in
the British army is taking the Ukrainian
soldiers through different stages of
training they're currently three weeks
into the program
first let's look at maneuvering some
drills are being taught on training
tanks which don't have turrets we are at
the point of the advanced sections and
that's more how to use the tank in a
tactical environment how fast you can
move it how much it can take essentially
before you have to basically rain in a
little bit gregori is a Ukrainian
Soldier learning these skills
foreign
the Challenger two tanks are slower than
the soviet-era t-72 vehicles as they are
heavier
Soviet era tanks are smaller and lighter
than Western tanks so they'll find it
easier to get up a steep hill because
they weigh 45 or 50 tons as opposed to
about 70 tons of a Challenger so when
you've got steep hills because the gun
might dig into the floor when you come
down the hill sometimes you'll need to
stop and put the gun over the side just
to get down a hill
then there's the differences in
Firepower
the Challenger 2 has a 120 millimeter
rifled barrel tank gun that means the
inside of the turret has grooves while
the t-72 uses what's known as a Smooth
Bore Armament which means it has a flat
interior
in theory rifling makes the gun more
accurate
but it also slightly slows down the
round the t72 has an autoloader so
there's a sort of circular cassette of
ammunition in the base of the turret
that's in contrast to the Challenger 2
which requires manual loading there are
four people who operate a challenger 2
tank we have a loader operator which is
different from the the tanks that they
have at the moment because they have an
auto loader in their tanks and we have a
person to do that the British army is
trying
similar to machine called a loaders
drill trainer or ldt this helps the crew
practice loading up the tank ready to
fire
the loader needs to know how to get the
big heavy 120 millimeter shell into the
breach of the Guard now that just needs
practice it's not a complicated task but
physically it's quite challenging and
it's even more challenging when the
vehicles in combat and moving around
Ukrainian forces are also learning to
maintain the vehicle so they can run
smoothly
we started off with a maintenance phase
and the technical details phase which is
all components how they work every
single aspect of the tank essentially
lessons include how to check these
rubber triangles situated on the wheels
they need regular checks during combat
tracked Vehicles do break down more
frequently than a wheeled vehicle over
some similar size
analysts say the Readiness of the
Ukrainian forces will depend on how
quickly they can learn
some of the Ukrainian armed forces have
operated tanks before but most of them
have not seen a tank
but getting to grips with Battlefield
tactics and the electronic systems on
board could be difficult for those
without prior experience according to
defense analysts the number of Western
Vehicles provided could also be a hurdle
for Ukraine Kiev requested 300 Western
tanks but defense experts say only
around 50 to 60 have been offered so far
Russian officials attacked the pledges
for tanks Kremlin spokesman Dimitri
peskov said Moscow sees them as
increasing the West's direct involvement
in the conflict
for the Ukrainian soldiers training here
in the UK the lessons could soon be put
into practice